من يلقي نظره سريعه على هذا المنزل لا
يجده مختلفا عن اي منزل اخر في هذا الشرعي
بضواحي غرب لندن باستثناء ساريه العلم
ولوحه السياره الدبلوماسيه
العلم للكوريا الشماليه والمنزل المكون من
سبع غرف يعود لصفارتها في لندن على عكس
السفاره الاخرى التي تتخذ من الاحياء
الراقيه كميثر وكنزه مقر لها
كاميرات مثبته في كل ركن من اركان المنزل
السفاره تثير مخاوف سكان هذا الشارع الذي
يبلغ متوسط سعر المنزل فيه
750 الف جنيه
الى وجودها في هذه الضحك السكنيه
لهذا الموقع لا يقلقني لا يزعجونني ولا
ازعجهم
كما نظام وكينج اون يحافظ ديبلوماسيو
وسفاره على سمعه بلدهم لناحيه السريه
الجديده لكنهم يختلطان في بعض المناسبات
مع عامه الناس فيما يظلون بعيدين كل البعد
عن اماكن اقامه السفراء الدول الاخرى
الاكثر فخامه في وسط لندن
اختيار موقع السفاره هنا في غرب لندن قد
يثير العديد من التساؤلات لكنه وفر ايضا
على بين اجاره باهضه على مدار 20 عاما
فالمال كان احدا العوامل الرئيسيه لاختيار
ضواحي العاصمه بحسب نائب سفير صادق انشق
عن النظام قبل ست سنوات ليلجا الى كوريا
الجنوبيه